welcome to this shuffle suffering I got
a light look at this look at it like wow
I have no idea every looks better or not
but yeah let's go back and kill some
babies because why not I like killing a
but prisoner ah [ __ ] me yeah can't get a
break here alright what should we do
whoa
I got doc on the roof come down here
actually please don't
you don't even have a head bro
watch dude going on here
did you really love her I don't think so
[Music]
yeah I guess it didn't really love her I
like the little splashy effect very nice
no I think we need to go that a shot
what's going on here and close the door
bro you get those right oh oh come on
what the hell
stop that [ __ ] all right
any bar you rip up two arms I make no
[ __ ] [ __ ] we get in the locker right
is it lock it every day yeah I would
smash the lock , Marbella oh thanks
what did someone say something no shoe
corroded super uber ahh drop the soap
that [ __ ]
all right bring it babies and trust that
Justin baby back we meet again
Justin me
oh nice ah bro I check it out of that
Holy Shetty there's no right that's my
bed all right bye
no I did come into the baguette I'll
rape you in the shower
wait a second
I hate you I hate you I hate all of you
give me a feedback like a stop no no no
I'm gonna die
hang on
[ __ ] how many of that holy [ __ ] maybe
the new tactic
alright machine gun huh that makes no
[ __ ] guys whatsoever doesn't even
matter what you say
just for good luck
who's training my health I don't get it
die die [ __ ] die oh it's coming yeah
gimme an a no stop respawning
come on where the [ __ ] am I supposed to
go
are you kidding me come on Vicki it's
gotta be an excess this is I came for
him yeah
come on all right you name it
you made me hurt but I'm gonna activate
yeah Wow
maybe activated my best customer [ __ ] I
hate you come on they don't die hey it's
a soap
alright maybe they died now I see you I
am shooting all of you you can dance all
you want I don't even [ __ ] care I
don't even have a health pack
that's right
that's right that's right dying if they
bleed he's come on Oh in here in here
wait no holidays I love that I love it
all right this looks correct no it's
slicing time because I don't have any
[ __ ] animal where is this I hope you
choke that's not very nice come on
[Music]
what about the fire extinguisher oh cool
I made it I thank God I'm a genius
the overseers what's up with you bro
they're all this and I thank God thank
baby Jesus
I can be bad after again control station
why the [ __ ] not
I progress a plant hired a lot of
batteries how you don't plan I'm stuck
I'm literally stuck sigh I'm psyching
the chaos that I don't want to redo all
that
oh come on why am i stock get up
game ever heard of the face I'm just
gonna rush this
my god
that's right all right
[ __ ] it you do anything alright what's
going on
let's go outside
thank God thank God they never die
even squeal like beer until I come on
the [ __ ] nightmare
give me some of that [ __ ] stop following
me be very good [ __ ] tonight did I
just walk in circle me they got
[ __ ] you gotta kill some anything
died
no one else
and they're all of you [ __ ] bring it
all you wanna dance
are you two done so I like what it here
I'm ready [ __ ]
thank you going in the air
[Applause]
yeah I like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah I guess holy [ __ ] he does we could
be fast you can be fast we could be felt
we could be fat
it could be
I think so all right Jim just [ __ ]
brings out the worst I was not raised by
the way
okay I was like all I amigos and they
were like come on each made bad I'd nor
activated oh you want to know my muscle
ah why do you do
you know anyone else where do you come
from
you're not decided [ __ ] hey dice
John what I wasn't even going closer
that's stupid
all right I'm gonna engineer brightest
but like a pretty vision direct force
catechol road right okay all right
Wow
back man
Oh